[Music]
last week American Apparel fired their
president and CEO Dov Charney let's
picture of him he's facing multiple
sexual harassment lawsuits as well as
new charges of sexual misconduct in the
office now also in the news for sexual
misconduct is fashion photographer Terry
Richardson who's being accused of
forcing himself on his models these are
two big stories now I noticed something
that these two men have in common you
may have as well the same pair of creepy
glasses that's right the same pair of
glasses also worn by Jeffrey Dahmer so I
just want to take a moment to address
all the ladies out there be suspicious
of any man wearing these glasses because
he's probably a creep and a sleaze bag
guy who purchased glasses like these
clearly didn't have a woman around to
talk him out of it at least not a live
woman so get this straight if you see a
man wearing these glasses immediately
turn and run and if he's also wearing a
tan windbreaker you can call the police
by the way there's only one pair of
glasses that's even creepier than these
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you